[Music]
you
[Applause]
well I'm the mid-south guy remember so
you don't have to ever since I started
this show I got a lot of requests to
review the movie cast stone dance
released in 1997 really this is seen as
a bad movie I mean I remember seeing it
a long time ago and I recall it being
okay not perfect but a serviceable film
a nice little kids movie with nice
animation and one or two labs I even
mentioned at one point I would never
review this movie because I didn't think
the flaws were bad enough to fill up an
entire review but then I started
thinking about it maybe you don't want
me to review this movie because it's so
bad but because it left an impact I'm
hearing more and more that this is one
of those movies that was played a lot on
Cartoon Network and even though it
bombed at the box office
it found life on VHS resulting in only
now a widescreen release on DVD and with
all the recommendations I've been
getting for it clearly it has a
following so what is it that draws so
many people to this animated flick why
not take a look this is my quick mini
review of cats don't dance it starts off
with a Randy Newman song that's nice as
we see a kid in the 1930s named Danny
played by Scott Bakula this will be the
greatest movie ever made this is all
secretly an identity from quantum leap
it's traveling to Hollywood to try and
become a star you can't do anything if
you try this that face ain't nothing
like it in the place is right above the
movie screen the first thing you might
notice about this film is that seems
well corny like Indiana can't supply
enough fuel for your corniness but
that's a couple things to keep in mind I
brought with a beautifully colorful and
lively animation this is a throwback to
musicals of that era which represents
Danny's optimism that's going to be - -
later on in the film Beck reality is
already kind of sinking in if the love
interest of the film is not introduced
through glitter in life but rather Danny
unknowingly screwing her over blinded by
his cheerfulness everything he does
somehow results in her misery also shit
Captain Archer is a good singer
I would wear the streets off pain go
where the kid is never and since of
course part smooth Danny enters a talent
agency coming across a slew of weirdos
and happens if they ever happen and the
talent agent just happens to need a cat
for a Noah's Ark picture just sign here
here and here here here and here dear no
but I have a cat crossed my path orange
body sharing the yeah
what are we getting Maginot well we're
doing well the music in seems like this
can get distractingly loud the pacing is
pretty impressive calling back to
classic fast-talking comedies of that
time like his girl Friday and bringing a
baby I'll give you some days I'll go
watch spend a nickel in here drummer
yeah no man suffering its back together
again just the way we use the face I'm
afraid of any time any days anyway don't
mock me this is bigger than anything
ever happened to watch only this time
the animation can magnify the movements
as well as the speech plus our love
interest Sawyer played by Jasmine guy
continues to comedic Lee be the subject
of Neela's violence the best kind of
violence I'm not usually brandable
cruelty by the Tom and Sawyer could get
together for a slapstick routine I
already have the perfect name Tom Sawyer
that's actually better lawyer gets roped
into a role - as they can't find a
female cat and they're off to shoot with
their main star a Shirley Temple
knockoff named Darla dimple played by
Ashley Tilden she's jealous because she
point out of our class this character is
by far the best part of the movie and
first you might be wondering what I'm
talking about but when Danny musically
improvises her reactions from here on
out are beyond priceless
when Lord Allah he's hot celebrity
darling I don't think there's enough
haunted houses for the amount of scary
faces she makes in this movie they're
all were finally insane and the
animation doesn't hold back in the
slightest making every reaction
hilarious even the one on the cover is
kind of disturbing she looks like
whoever possessed Regan in The Exorcist
with such a light-hearted tone for the
rest of the film this is an enjoyably
cynical approach to a child icon it's
kind of weird but also funny this idea
of turning a Shirley Temple type persona
into a villain it's equivalent of
showing the Olsen twins of villains or
the Jerry Maguire kid as a villain or
that was for real this leads to the only
character who might actually be funnier
than Darla her Butler max when she
called for him we don't even see him
approach he's already inside the angle
of they used to show the size of this
guy are simple in layout but
ridiculously effective
he never even separates his teeth to say
a word and when he put Danny in his
places exit perfectly through the hem
shaped hole is inspiringly extreme
I don't think Batman could have an exit
that good when Danny tried to figure out
what he did wrong Sawyer laid some blunt
reality on him leaving the probably the
film's most poignant line all I want to
do is the thing I love doesn't everyone
but Danny finds out he's not the only
one with dashed dreams he comes across
an elephant named woolly mammoth who's
the logo for the studio which he has to
do every time they make a movie this
cracks me up because it would be so much
easier just to shoot it once and reuse
the footage but every time a movie is
made yet the squeeze his head through
get made up and he has to do the sound
effect all over again
that's just enjoyably pointless it's
made even funnier by the fact that he's
apparently a piano player oh he has
hooves or paws or whatever elephant
hands are called how does he hit the
keys I know it's a small thing but that
really makes me laugh Danny finds out
that Willy wanted to be a musician but
the Hollywood system chewed him up and
spat him out just like all the rest of
his new friends apparently Hollywood
just isn't interested in animals as
weeds but I thought Hollywood was always
looking for new talented people not
animals
when will human washing stop but Danny
thinks he can inspire everybody again
and brings out some old costumes and
instruments to have fun with the color
literally comes back into their lives in
fact the use of colour to show their
constant conflicting emotions is very
clever when they're interested they
start to glow and become more vibrant
but when they're not they step back into
the shadows Oh once again the colour is
removed it's subtle but it's very smart
Darla sees that Danny is going to try
and get an audition with a big-time
producer and she's afraid that their
talent might have stayed hers
okay if Sharon Leno harness this kind of
creepiness we would have a much better
Joker Darla and bikes Danny over to her
house it offers him and his animal
friends her studio and props to all
tissue for the big-time producer lb
mammoth little does Danny know that lb
doesn't know and they're about to crash
an important press conference cue the
most maniacally when I call a blast is
it wrong that I'm siding with the
villain and I really think she should
have her own movies we get a pretty fun
villain song obviously making every
person who worked on it the happiest
animators in the world must the animals
show up to the studio but Darla floods
the stage putting the press conference
as well as the entire studio underwater
all the animals are fired and they of
course blame Danny leading of course to
a sad song from Sawyer doing her best a
Tony Cohen version
[Music]
it's not bad but if you heard Sally's
song from a Nightmare Before Christmas
and just put a little cat ears on top of
her head it's pretty much the same thing
but Danny gets an idea on how to redeem
himself as well as get some revenge he
invites everyone to the premiere of her
movie planning to show everyone what
they can do but max here's a bowtie snap
and is literally God in the next shot
the only thing funnier than what we see
with this guy is what we don't see Danny
and Max have a big fight on top of a
Darla balloon one of the strangest
setting for a climax since David
Hasselhoff and Danny eventually sent in
flies his results in the animals going
on to perform and making it look like it
was Darla's idea
the audience is resistant but they give
him a chance and of course they love
even with Darla trying to stop them yet
again she only ends up making the show
even better she accidentally exposed as
her evil plans to everyone resulting in
her career being destroyed any animals
acting in movies that wouldn't be
released for 60 years and that is cat
don't dance is it corny yeah are the
times where the music and sound effects
are a little much absolutely but how did
the hudsucker proxy put it in the nice
school years later you know for kids
some movies are for families this is
clearly for kids that is to say there
are definitely elements for adults Darla
is great her Butler is great the
callbacks to classic Hollywood are nice
and honestly you could argue there's a
good lesson about prejudice in there
it's in spite of being called the Golden
Age of cinema there were still many
groups that were kept out of it if you
replace the animals in this movie with
many minority groups you could actually
have yourself a pretty fitting
commentary is that what they had in mind
I don't know it could be a very simple
follow your dream story but if Who
Framed Roger Rabbit can be about cartoon
animal feeling with racism why can't
this and if you think it's too strange
or goofy to be enjoyed look at the
bright side
Michael Jackson was going to be a part
of it yeah no joke this was originally
supposed to star a live-action Michael
Jackson with animated characters wanting
to be movie stars
in fact at one point it was supposed to
be the Looney Tunes but after Jackson
dropped out they gave the Looney Tunes
movie to Michael Jordan and kept the
story going because hey maybe there was
something there you go without Jackson
not again I think there is if you look
at any of the kids bill it's not going
to entertain both adults and children
perfectly like The Iron Giant comes and
are spirited away but as colorful
energized and has a good message for
kids while also having some great
expressions into cynicism and nice
elutes to the early days of film for
adults it's not a classic but it's a
good film it's a little cheesy but if
done well cheesy is fine
it's definitely worth showing to
children and maybe you too can sneak a
peek and gain just the right amount of
enjoyment from it how that phrase go
against him Robbins you know for kids
exactly but you know what sometimes
there's no fault in wanting to feel like
a kid again and this is a good film to
do them I'm not a thousand a guy
remember so you don't have to
[Music]
[Applause]
you